Alright.
So, we've written this XMLHttp request code a few times now. Let's go ahead and
extract it out. What I'd like you to do is fill out the function xhrGet that
does, well, exactly what we've done the past couple of times with xhrs. Takes in
the request URI, like weapon.json, or bg_menu.ogg,
it takes in a callback function to set the onload function too and it takes in
a type, which could be either nothing, if we're expecting text data or
arraybuffer, if we are expecting arraybuffer data. Now, one quick note
about the callbacks, we're going to create the callbacks such that we assume that it takes
the request object as a parameter. So, for example, you can see our parseJSON
function here takes the xhr, and then parses xhr.responseText. Now, we have both
the parseJSON and playSound functions here, that if passed in as callbacks, will
appropriately play sound or parseJSON as we've done before. Now, down at the
bottom of this file, we make 2 calls to xhrGet with weapon.json and bg_menu.ogg.
Just for you to test again to make sure that your xhrGet function is behaving
properly.